Pam is with us in New York hi Pam
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thanks for having me
sure what's up so I guess my question is
I just feel like I'm starting my life a
little bit late my husband and I are
both physicians I just finished my
residency in pediatrics this past summer
and so on my first real job we're
currently in New York my husband has one
more year of training to go in
fellowship so we'll be moving to the
North Carolina pretty soon but we're
both looking at about six hundred fifty
six six hundred thirty thousand and
student loans combine so my question is
so that matter how we start paying it
down should we work on one first or just
attack them both equally and how does
house down payment work into that planet
if at all it doesn't you need to clean
this mess up
you guys are you have a massive scary
amount of that and what's his felish
what's his specialisation and we'll see
fellowshipping um I'll be done with
neuroradiology okay and so what are your
project that incomes when you're both
completely out so the job I just took
it'll be about 180 for the first six
months so essentially 90,000 and then
the projected income is about three
hundred thirty at the at the practice
the previous position okay so your your
projected incomes 330 what is his when
he comes out anywhere from 270 to 300
starting up to about maybe 400 you know
when he's them okay so let's just kind
of look at the shovel to hole ratio
which is what I look at the hole is
really scary at six hundred and thirty
thousand but the shovel is seven hundred
thousand right well a year I know but
not today but I'm saying it with in the
near future within the foreseeable
future so that that that's how you
address that and you say so I'm going to
be student loan debt free easily in two
years
once the seven hundred kicks in right
yeah I guess so yeah so we're not I'm
not saying don't buy a house for a
decade I'm saying this is a legitimate
mess you have an absolutely crazy
wonderful income in your future which
I'm proud for you I'm glad you're making
that and you know in the meantime let's
just start whittling on the debt but as
the incomes come up yours
and then as he finishes the fellowship
and his income kicks in delay purchases
don't have doc itis and go buy stuff
delay purchases you've been holding your
breath a long time to get to this point
now you got to clean up the last mess
before you move on to purchases then we
start talking about buying a car that
you pay cash for buying a house and cred
you got to pay it off in no time you
guys are going to be very wealthy if
you're careful with this but you cannot
out on your stupidity you have to have a
plan and you have to execute and clear
the debt and way to go Wow crazy
wonderful numbers